next on book TV an insider's perspective
of Silicon Valley and the tech world
with former Twitter advisor and Facebook
product manager Antonio Martinez
right should we start I don't know yeah
I was I was waiting for somebody's I
didn't notice I'm going to kick it up
okay so you saw me furiously doing is I
was completely unprepared and I came to
a reading without my own copy of the
book which is really funny I thought I'd
have to buy my own book
fortunately they yeah I know I think
they do sell them are the mics on
because I can't hear myself very well
but no I don't have it on right I could
just scream but at some point my voice
is going to give out
testing testing other again okay I just
need to hold the closer so what I was
finding where the is there a format to
this is like half an hour of reading and
then QA up to me okay so when we will do
a few readings and then some QA and then
maybe not as many readings as in the
past because the QA tends to stretch out
for a long time and I want to give you a
chance to ask questions if you have them
but the passages were reading fYI the
reading I did in the city
I held a poll on Facebook of course
because the the chip they implanted in
my brain still work so I can just write
to Facebook as I as I speak and we need
a poll what are the best passages or the
passages most most that most wanted to
be read right and so I'll give you some
input but I'll read you the list it is
so the top winner in the poll which
surprised me was the final Sheryl
meeting where I get where where fbx gets
shot down and I realized my life is over
basically the famous sexist paragraph
that will evidently go on my tombstone
which you know what I'm talking about
it's the yeah someone that gets quoted
in every review unfortunately completely
out of context of course and then number
three which surprised me was the meeting
with Baz who's the the Facebook guy who
runs ads and we had this sort of weird
mafia boss style meeting and then the
fourth one was the homebrewing story
where I blew up the plumbing and flooded
Zuck's desk so is there any other scene
that somebody wants us a reading that
you're willing to raise your hand and
propose oh hey dude some of the
characters in the book are actually
standing here just by the way just FYI
if you look good
you're free to out yourselves or not
actually the last reading british trader
was there my kids were there like all
the secret members wherever they didn't
they chose not to out them
I think you could figure out yet the
other the Israeli with the face like a
sheet of plywood you can judge for
yourself whether that's true or not
here's Ilona meet the former head of
optimization at Facebook who interviewed
me at Facebook and made the crazy
decision I assume you said it yes
because that's I got hired but anyhow so
ok anybody else have another passage you
really want me to read and you're
willing to like raise your hand and say
I want you to read that one feel free
I'm not rolling like actually if you
really want me to read a certain passage
by all means No
so you're cool with the four that I've
chosen I might give up before I get to
the end but definitely the first two I
have to read okay okay so I'll do some
readings and then I'll do a Q&A and then
I think I'm I assume it would have a
signing after if you actually want to
sign okay so the final Sheryl meeting
and so the context you I don't know how
many of you have read it yet or not the
context here is that I got myself into a
massive political pissing match to
Facebook about the future of Facebook
and I ended up losing the political
struggle because I'm obviously a bit
Ematic and you know articulate
individual who could obviously didn't
make it in the Facebook's make bit
anyhow so the scene here is Facebook's
sorry Cheryl's Freudian slip Cheryl's
conference room called only good news
yeah oh yes [ __ ] sorry okay is that
better
do I sound like the voice of God now in
the entire store again what's that I'm
on page 465 Dateline April 12 2013 the
chapters called it ad major on Facebook
lo diem okay so the scene here is when
it's like I've played every card I can
and like it's the final meeting hey man
see another character from the book it's
like all of Facebook ads the former
Facebook ads is going to show up
I don't think current facebook ads going
to show but I'm happy to be to be
disappointed anyhow so the scene was
this final Sheryl meeting were like
that's it
like they decided to decide and they're
not going to probably go my way
so the theme was the only good news
conference room we've returned to our
starting point and again FYI for those
who haven't read this is the exact same
scene with you almost the exact same
characters as the first chapter in the
book a year earlier literally a year
earlier oh sorry yeah
would return to our starting point but
under very different circumstances the
cast was almost exactly the same Gokul
Boland wrapkin Sherrill and now Baz
I have played every last card FBX
development so I have to be excellent if
you don't know if you go browse the
Internet and then you go see whatever
the hell you looked at inside your
Facebook experience so we built that FBX
is what does that effectively and so you
have me to blame for that days ago well
and the guy behind and that is Roberta
do cos he was the PM to the computing
solution Meo so FBX development had been
pushed to its absolute max despite what
little resources we had using either
flattery or deception we'd gotten FBX
partners to spend as much money as
possible on the new platform I had tried
the charm and persuade with whatever
persuasive charisma had worked on
investors and co-founders in the past
the other members of the ads team to
support a vision most of them barely
understood that was the good on the bad
side I had been insubordinate to Gokul
more or less refusing to work on the
[ __ ] make work projects he designed
to distract me from FBX I've been an
insufferably obnoxious Punk on the ads
team pushing for a contrarian agenda and
a culture rapidly losing its supposed
tolerance for heterodoxy well FBX had
been a qualified success and I had
received praise for doing much with very
little
none of the Earth's while FBX fans in
that room were not willing to stake any
of their internal social capital on its
future much less on the overarching
programmatic direction it represented if
Sheryl agreed to extend to FBX the data
joining that was currently limited to
custom audiences or to even put mobile
ads inventory on FBX there was a chance
of pulling this off if Cheryl didn't
agree then it would mean the death of
FBX and everything around it the
technology itself the innovative IP we
had patented the budgets we've secured
the work on the FPS partners had done to
integrate the bigger vision of it all
gone we were all in embedding on just
one card being drawn you want to go
ahead buzz Cheryl gestured to Boz who is
sitting across from me
pauses the head of ads who's like this
big bold bully with tattoos on his arms
again after talking to everyone
concerned including the custom audience
and FBX teams I think we shouldn't ship
identity matching on FBX that's where
like who you are gets matched to every
device in the world and sold to everyone
I want
okay and continue with it on custom
audiences only that's my recommendation
this was going to be a short meeting
everyone here has contributed to this
discussion right Cheryl looked around
the table we all nodded well that's what
you think buzzed and that's what we'll
do
I caught Bob his eye he looked away
nobody moves or spoke after so many
months of discussion it was hard to
believe that incision had actually been
made
Cheryl added finally as if trying to
snap us out of a stupor so that's it
nothing of custom audiences on FBX
no mobile inventory on FBX either we'll
leave it as it is and keep pressing on
with identity on custom audiences alone
I looked at the window at an alleyway
that led to the main courtyard and the
huge hack sign pointing skyward like a
divine commandment well I had certainly
hacked after some closing formalities
that I was too distracted to register
everyone got up to leave there was
nothing left to discuss
Gokul glanced in my direction but looked
away the moment our eyes met and darted
out of the room he was out of the
building before I could even attempt to
catch up I wandered into the fbx area or
what was left of it the product I had
gambled my entire Facebook career on was
now effectively on life support for the
second time in two years I walked out of
the office in the middle of the
afternoon with nothing to do so that was
the death of SPX effectively shed a tear
okay so the next one is the one where I
get embarrassed is the sexist paragraph
so the context here is that I knocked up
the story I barely knew on the fourth
date okay that's the context and three
months later she announces that she use
pregnant and so again I'm going to read
the full quote okay not be out of
context when the other reviewers read
page 57 on the right hand side in the
middle
she had wild green eyes with unnatural
spots in her irises when you pulled
close reminiscent of that Afghan girl
from the National Geographic cover her
personality was flimsy and rough and has
led very as her skin she had spent years
between various jobs backpacking around
the rougher parts of the world
she was an imposing broad shouldered
presence six feet tall and bare feet and
towering over me in heels
he goes most women in the Bay Area are
soft and weak cosseted in naive despite
their claims of worldliness
and generally full of [ __ ] they have
their self regarding entitlement
feminism and ceaselessly want their
independence but the reality is come the
epidemic plague or foreign invasion
they've become precisely the sort of
useless baggage you trade for a box of
shotgun shells or a jerrican of diesel
crucify me now and again point contrast
British trader on the other hand okay
was the sort of woman who would end up a
useful Ally in the post apocalypse doing
whatever work be a carpentry animal
husbandry or a shotgun blast of
someone's back required doing long story
short you want to tie your genetic wagon
to the bucking horse of her bloodline
which is why I was less nervous and I
should have been on a random Saturday in
July when I showed up for a brunch
appointment and found her uncle
characteristically moody she complained
of feeling nauseated and slightly out of
it with perhaps too much off handedness
while grabbing a local newspaper off her
couch I suggested well perhaps to a
pregnancy test
like any male who's played it fast and
loose with the safe sex rules
I had my fair share of scares I was on
season 4 of the show whereby tear-filled
woman ex showed up two weeks after the
shag saying she had quote missed her
period sort of in the same way I'd say I
missed my bus nothing had ever come a
bit and after the third show and you
just wanted to say look woman unless
you've got a screaming infant in your
arms and it looks like me we have
nothing to talk about
she'd have both soon enough well I did
go to the doctor she replied instantly
thanks took on a rather portentous air
for a casual Saturday morning brunch ah
and I am pregnant BAM a human life
[ __ ] I thought I could hear God laughing
and his vault that hang out life is what
happens when you're making other plans
indeed alright so do you want me to stop
there keep on with the baz scene which
is the other one one more okay where's
the buzzing okay so what you can choose
there's a home brewing scene where I've
loved the plumbing and then there's like
the me meeting with the mafia boss of
buzz buzz buzz buzz Keith okay well do
on a boat I don't know lo ok who says
the boss scene
good [ __ ] that's wait for eight nine ten
is that time yeah no no sorry 12 well
that's yeah twelve okay so twelve for
for the boss did I just say buzz-buzz
yeah okay and then for the homebrew
scene okay sorry
the boss takes it what are the
super-delegates say nah I'm joking
so where's the Buffy okay
wait no hon okay how did for this
dumpling Don
okay so positive the head of a Bad's and
he the reason why he was there is
because he was sucks TA at Harvard right
that's why he was there and he you know
I don't know if you saw the movie The
Social Network just erased it as a model
for like what Facebook is really like is
really not like that at all but um Boz
was this ti and and at some point ads
became total pandemonium which is what I
described in the book and and Zack
basically sent bust just like unscrew
ads and figure out what the hell is
going on because he's one of the few
guys that he trusts thread and so and
Baz has no no background in dads at all
whatsoever but Boz was no longer the
dilettante guest of the ads team sitting
in like a tourist on meetings but the
officially installed leader he carried
himself like he owned the place which of
course he kind of did bosses takeover of
ads represented more than a cosmetic
shift in the organizational chart we're
witnessing the complete reconfiguration
of the ad space time continuum along the
single dimension from balls likes you to
fired where you were in that continuum
with yet to be determined for most ads
folks and I had no idea where I fell to
figure this out Boz requested we have a
one on one even though I didn't report
to him officially does on page 457 by
the way I know you can ask in short
order I found myself sitting across from
him at a small table in a small
conference room staring at the tattoos
gracing his forearms on his right there
was a figurative map of California on
his left the word Betty dust encircled
his wrists truth in Latin also Harvard's
motto I had of course done a complete
Facebook stock going back through his
time at Harvard and clear into babyhood
thanks to the SP hash tag pound TBT I
had seen his idealized and mediated
autobiography from rural Northern
California to Harvard to Facebook I had
also scoped out his management
philosophy or really his public
conception of it he clearly was one of
those tough but fair types who pride
themselves on directness and honesty
truth was written on his body after all
for my part outside of physics textbooks
I found truth to be a rather rare
commodity particularly in the tech world
I had also noticed that those who most
made a big show of believing in truth
were unusually unusually attached to
whatever will groom pack of lies they
held dear
the conversation proceeded quickly to my
role in the ads team at Facebook the
performance review cycle will semiannual
with every February and August bringing
the usual political jockeying to make
sure your biggest fans reviewed you and
your biggest detractors didn't quite
manage to you're a very divisive figure
Antonio I read the reviews of your team
members and then that of management
they're completely opposed one loves you
and the other hates you okay that's also
true in my Amazon reviews you're either
all five or once they're yeah no [ __ ]
I could imagine the feedback would that
haven't been told the specific authors
Riesman Hari and Gary and other members
on the FBX team all gushing praise for
my dedication and product leadership and
then go Colombo l'm decrying my uncouth
insubordination smart alec e arrogance
and corrosive criticism of current
facebook strategy that's true buzz I've
certainly made friends and enemies here
but my goal has always been to give
facebook that that's the best ads team
possible this was in all seriousness
true I could barely remember what my
life was like before Facebook and there
was a trail of destruction I'd caused by
spending my entire life their two
children neglected two different women
who's worthy loved I'd spurned two boats
rotting and neglect and anything like an
intellect or a life outside campus
non-existence non-existent due to
indifference and my dedication to the
Facebook cause don't be deceived by my
withering treatment of Facebook in this
book inside every cynic Liz a
heartbroken idealist if I'm now a
mourning critic it's because at one
point like Lucifer once being the
proudest angel before the fall I too
lived and breathed for Facebook perhaps
even more than most we moved on to the
topic of the open versus closed debate
that was rolling all of us while he was
equivocal in the matter he expressed his
firm intent to come to a conclusion
quickly and end the uncertainty that
plagued every forward-looking decision
ads was making this was one of those
Delphic portents of old which could be
read either somewhat positively or
negatively depending afterward we stood
up and shook it we stood up and shook
hands over the small desk the meeting
had the smell of a last meeting with the
Mafia capo before things turned ugly and
he started either unleashing hitmen or
making offers that couldn't be refused I
didn't like the smell of it not one bit
we know how that ended but yeah okay so
up there and just go to a QA time or one
more the homebrew okay we're in a
satisfied hungry people [ __ ] now I lost
my Marge
a little bit again sorry closer not
further yeah I feel like I'm wrong and
so sorry I'm looking upon brain 406 is
anyone is anyone here from the home
brewing kit is scott here or chris now
yeah
Oh is he okay he could provide necessary
context all right who's the footnote it
was like a chapter but we cut it this is
a true story as is everything else in
the book by the way believe it or not
when I moved on to the boat I had to put
my home brewing apparatus somewhere so I
stored it on Facebook's campus of course
come some hackathon aided by some of the
other craft beer degenerates including
Chris who's not here yet I deployed the
five-gallon brew set up all the while
draining a respectable stockpile of
Belgian ales when it came time to chill
the boiled proto beer we connected a
large coil of copper tubing to the
faucet in the second-floor kitchen of
building 16 we were apprised of the fact
it was raining on zux desk and that of
every other member of senior management
which was directly underneath the
kitchen when security rushed in with
panic faces evidently we had burst the
plumbing in the kitchen with our high
pressure cooling undaunted our brave
beer crew who are in a state of
considerable inebriation finished the
brew and left a large carboy to ferment
in the ads area for four o'clock that
morning upon reaching quasi sobriety and
recalling my duties as product manager
of this venture I sent an apologetic
email the Zek promising a bottle of the
brew as recompense there were no
repercussions from our lark and I still
owe suck a bottle as we check the beer
instead which was excellent we killed it
inside of an hour move fast and break
things including the plumbing move fast
and break things being one of the more
famous sort of facebook slogans that you
see on the coasters all right so there
goes the reading what's next
QA
I'm Harriet ma I'm the event coordinator
here and we were so lucky to get on
Tonio to come thank you so much because
he just had a baby
well he didn't but someone did yeah he
is a proud father yes if you have any
questions we'd like to take some
questions but if people use these mics
over here if you can line up behind the
mic if you have any questions wise are
two mics this one's supposed to try
advance I'm scared don't worry I'll get
okay and yes sir I'll stop asking
questions all right
cue a colleague got me somebody
yeah yes sure
oh so better than depicted in the book
better than you might want to say into
mic you sorry you anything in the book
you don't seem to have much relationship
with your children so I'm wondering do
you have one now yeah yeah yeah so yeah
I mean the book is a snapshot in time
obviously right like that was the fate
of the relation for the time and in fact
it was in some ways worse than I
depicted because there was like a whole
child support case yeah there's a bunch
of ugliness I was going at but anyhow so
long story short
yeah no it's pretty good now so I still
see them you know the mother British
trader is as independent and ferocious
as she's always been and so recently she
decided to go traveling the world with
the kids so single mother with two kids
and they they took off by a week ago and
so they're going to visit family New
Zealand and Israel and stuff so you know
they're going to go see the world but
now I've been part of their lives so
they're not a huge part of their lives
for the past you know six years they're
four and six right now and yeah I know
they're doing well you know they're they
don't quite understand the book yet I
think but I've given the copy with that
oh yeah and so if you read the
acknowledgments you'll see a reference
to a French architect again another code
name and so yes indeed
so well without personal question right
so the the child was conceived the day I
got the book deal actually and the child
came out right when this book came out
literally exactly forty weeks later and
perfect timing in all regards and so yes
there was another woman in C yeah this
it's three months old and at least came
out
and that's another kind of strange
situation but it's funny the mothers are
very similar to each other you know very
independent obviously I have a type
probably the only woman who actually can
put up with me but um yeah so sure there
we go to Facebook who showed up
so I wanted this song you have to get
really close to it I think testing I
don't think it's on no I'll just I'll
just talk loud okay so I wanted to know
if you have kept your Facebook stock
after leaving or as you've disposed of
it and if you've kept it would we
consider that as an endorsement oh my
god sir for where Facebook is heading
and if you dispose of it do you regret
doing that so I think it takes it in the
book that I sold well I I did sell all
about all of it actually wait which I
say from the book which was like a
obviously hideous error but the reason
why I mention that in there is because I
went to spoiler but if you read the
epilogue the epilogue tells you like
what happened after right and so how did
Facebook sort of save itself from the
revenue crisis that I described and it
was very accidental OHS through mobile
right so I don't know how I mean it's
Mountain you so will get a little wonky
you know Facebook about I guess what six
months to a year many people here can
correct me went more than 50 percent
mobile and one of the great crews that
they pulled off which is absolutely to
the credit I mentioned in the epilogue
is that they and it was completely
unexpected again I didn't see it coming
out like enemies are coming that
suddenly mobile would be the savior and
so you know there's a saying in
marketing that money follows eyeballs
right and if you look at like
merrymakers internet sites minimum area
meters is equity analysts you'll see
this massive gap between where the
eyeballs are an internet and like the
money following it and like just a lot
of money in TV even though the eyeballs
aren't there but in the case of Facebook
they kind of broke that mold and they
made they made the money follow the
eyeballs in the span of a few quarters
or less and so Facebook went from I
guess when I left I don't know maybe 40
percent mobile to whatever it is now
which i think is 85% mobile in the most
recent quarter was just incredible and
they actually built an entire business
around that completely unexpectedly and
so you know I criticized Facebook a
little bit for being a little bit
unplanned they don't have they don't
they simply do not have a 5 or 10 year
plan it just does not exist right but on
the other hand they improvised really
well and when things come up that are
unexpected they can capitalize on those
in ways that no other company could I
mean if you consider I was just talking
about somebody else if you look at other
messaging apps like AOL or Yahoo like
that you know so many companies are
dying because that's just a mobile and
Facebook just like made that happen like
nothing as soon as people realize it oh
my god holy [ __ ] like all the money is
actually falling with the rivals are and
so I didn't see that coming basic I
didn't expected to have them and so yeah
I sold most the stock
I'm still pretty bullish on Facebook in
general I mean they still have positive
elements to their to their culture and
stuff you know and we're now gonna be
talking about stuff but yeah I mean I
I'm not gonna give a buy yourself six
awesome Facebook but I'm not negative on
the company at all it's not going to go
away anytime soon all the rumors about
teens aren't on Facebook whatever that's
all like that's complete [ __ ]
basically yeah yeah sure okay who's next
now put me on the spot which is a [ __ ]
which means it's a good question but I
forget where I read it I think this week
that didn't Procter gamble decide to
with yeah
decrease their advertising and Facebook
because they didn't find it very
effective yeah I mean is there's a
possibility every other people will
suddenly realize that it may not so much
project right I didn't find that even so
the new stories at P&G and I don't know
all the details maybe people here are
know more details but basically they
publicly announce is really weird for
these things when like ad campaigns
don't work out you usually don't have
public announcement about it but P&G
said that yeah
Facebook targeting isn't working for our
brand campaigns we're not going to use
it any or we're going to scale down our
facebook budget and you know if you read
the book right like it's not even
remotely surprising right like one of
the things I was the first facebook ads
targeting product manager hired by you
partially and you know we I spent a year
trying to turn Facebook data into money
and it didn't work right like likes an
interest if you're actually doing direct
response advertising we're trying to get
like a really positive response is is is
a marginal is a marginal result really
and so of course in ad tech it doesn't
have to actually work for you to sell it
right so you can you can I mean I think
I call in the book you know the the
brand advertisers like the legacy of
mission student of the advertising world
right it's the person who's there due to
relationships and steak dinners and
inertia and the chief marketing officer
afford being some old fuddy-duddy and
whatever else right and so they owe
their jobs that literally being the
legacy admissions Canada marketing world
right and then yeah I mean five years
after was evident anyone who was looking
you know Procter & Gamble wakes up and
says you know if we target people who
like Crest toothpaste it turns out they
don't find more to see yeah no [ __ ]
[ __ ] right and they liked it two years
ago for whatever reason and it doesn't
actually signal any intent whatsoever
why would it right and so yeah I mean
I'm just I guess I'm not surprised
is my answer so where was the Facebook
located while you work there in context
of book was ah in Menlo Park or so it
was actually so when I joined it was
still on HTML and kallab actually drove
by on the way here if you drive up
kallab does Emma know to hell those
buildings are nothing they got torn down
they got torn down yeah it was like an
old like industrial lab like nothing
special looking I'm I don't know I don't
know what it was well oh no no no no no
no no no no no no no and then they move
to what used to be the old Sun
Microsystems thing if you go to the end
of Willow Road it's this massive campus
thing and now they're building onto the
other side into Menlo Park but it's like
a facially Menlo Park but it's really
across the street from EPA or East Palo
Alto but where you're from your firm and
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and the cool thing about the
seventh one was that they intentionally
left like a corporate mint Amaury some
of the logos of sun like in some
conference rooms precisely as a reminder
like literally it was the ruins of the
previous civilization unless we fall
into the same trap we have to avoid the
the cultural death that that represents
that was not always like these little
classical touches all right you could
comment on the reception of the title of
your book in whether it has any
relationship to information theory in
monkeys type into typewriters no so it's
funny the the first title for the book
was way more wonky than this it was the
original title was actually pseudo
randomness which some of you geeks
probably know is the sort of fake
randomness that machines produce because
they're not true statistical randomness
the idea being that like my life was
pretty random so whatever but then it's
funny they totally schnockered me and
they said okay we'll do a book it will
keep the title and then like a month or
like you know screw the title I'll get
rid of it and so cats monkeys actually
is also kind of wonky but different in a
different way it's a it's a diagnostic
software package that Netflix developed
and that basically what a monkey running
through a data center like kicking over
boxes and what it does is it literally
goes and kills various boxes inside his
data center and they test them see if
like house of cards still streams or
whatever right and some version of a
caste monkeys isn't built probably by
every major sort of internet company
what you want to name what I meant by it
metaphorically though was that you know
Silicon Valley is like the zoo where the
cows monkeys are kept right and and what
happens is a company
uber says you know what we're not going
to have taxis anymore taxi medallions
will be worth $0 we're going to have a
mobile app and anybody who wants to be a
taxi driver can suddenly Drive
effectively a taxi or you know what
we're not going to have hotels anymore
we're gonna have this thing called
Airbnb and anyway the spare bedroom can
do their own thing and you know it's
funny I part of this book was written in
Barcelona and Berlin actually other part
last year and I went to Barcelona which
is Airbnb largest real estate market in
Europe and Barcelona has been like
completely roiled and arguably ruined by
Airbnb right there's entire I stayed and
nothing but Airbnb for three months okay
there's entire like apartment blocks
that are nothing but effectively Airbnb
colonies in Barcelona right in like the
prettier parts of town and of course
nobody invests in renovating it because
they're just trying to milk it for the
Airbnb thing if you go to these
buildings and it's just full of a bunch
of like drunk British and Swedish and
American tourists right thanks to Airbnb
and you know it's just like you know
literally what like you know 40 years of
fascism couldn't destroy it and same
thing in Berlin but I you know or like
you know the US Air Command during World
War two could not manage this I'm not
you know Airbnb is destroying Berlin in
Barcelona effectively right and so
that's what I mean by the chaos monkeys
phenomena basically pulling the plug on
everything and everyone is just kind of
like trying to survive you know the
result of that but that's that's where
the title came from I'm not gonna dive
into that but I mean yeah arguably they
are yeah thanks going to speak today
um I wondering what what what inspires
you to write a book I mean you weren't a
writer before right so what's funny I
did that for seven jobs thing if you'll
done that that meme you know this is
like you supposed to post like your
first seven jobs or whatever and like
the big reveal as my first job was
actually as a journalism intern in South
Florida in the late in the mid 90s
actually and so I really feel I've been
a writer like master baking being a
technology guy actually and so the
writing thing was always part of the
intent to some degree I mean I think if
you know it's a stretch for me to say I
was under deep cover
and I was like embedded in Facebook just
to create the book but to some degree
that that's somewhat true actually and I
always knew I'd write it and that's why
the dates are all right and everything's
documented cuz I was taking notes
throughout the course of the thing so it
was it was in the back of my mind but I
again spoiler at the end of the book I
mentioned my mother dies right and
that's like a trigger to like reevaluate
your life and you know when that happens
you're like well what's on my bucket
list
while writing this book
right and the real reason if you really
want to know why everyone asks why maybe
I'm taking some one of your questions
you know with the document I think we
live in amazing times just to get a
little grandiose for a moment like this
is like what we're living through like
think about this where's my phone right
everything all of human knowledge is now
live in that device right and your
entire social life is now mediated by
this I mean think about that
I'm old enough to remember not just no
smartphones no Bickley as computing like
I was raised in a library with looking
card cataloging to sit there and flip
and find a thing right so to realize
where we are it's just crazy right
people will look back at our time and
think of this like Gutenberg's printing
press or the Industrial Revolution or
whatever right and you look around and
nobody's documenting it right in my
opinion the last decent insider tell-all
memoir is a book called startup by Jerry
Kaplan and it's 20 years old right and
it's really good it's a good book but
it's really dated right and so I wanted
to create to some degree that and so
that you know a century from now people
ask what was it like back in the day you
know this might be one of the dozen
books that are sort of you know referred
to and so that's why I decided to commit
professional suicide and write the book
cool so kind of along the lines the last
two questions Oh what was the process
writing the book talk a little bit about
that about did you just sit down over
the course of a few months and bang it
all out or was it really torturous going
over and over it again or so I'm just
saying hi to the guy we do read the home
brewing scene and you were here yeah
it's crisp Ray's Philip that's a joke
so here is the process I knew I wanted
to write it mother dies I decide to sell
everything I moved to Europe because I
thought my career be overs have to
reboot my startup saying somewhere else
like I thought I'd literally be like a
fugitive right and so I go to Europe
start writing a little bit and then you
you write what kind of book proposals
always like the pitch then you sell the
agent on you and then the agent sells
you to the publishers basically and then
you get a book deal and they wanted to
do this this was August of last year
they wanted to be like the summer beach
read of this year and if you know the
book world doing a book in a year is
like it is like Lightspeed like it just
does not happen right and so that like
but we were looking at 10 months and so
I got the book deal and then I
remembered the place close to the place
where I bought my most recent boat which
is up in what's called the San Juan
Islands which is beautiful and gorgeous
and none of you should ever go there
because it should remain unspoiled but
it's these beautiful islands between
Seattle and Cooper Island and so I
managed to snag a place there and I
basically locked myself in there like
the Unabomber and wrote all day and
drank too much and stressed and raged
and pissed off my editor and you know I
managed to submit the manuscript by
whenever it was Thanksgiving Christmas
or so and then there was like four or
five months of editing and legal review
and all the rest of it and then you know
out it came 40 weeks after the exactly
40 weeks after the book the the book
deal is struck yeah I would advise you
not to write a blog everyone's talking
with idea a little bit destroy at least
a year to your life for sure like that
question yeah I haven't had a chance to
read your book only the little bit of it
but what I do get from it is it's sort
of the tell-all about which brings out
some of what's wrong brutal about
capitalism as practiced in Silicon
Valley so here's my question to you in
in your journey have you ever thought
about can we do better than capitalist
yeah I get asked a question by the way
there's a bunch of like Marxist [ __ ] in
the book too if you want to read it the
scene with the IPO I'm like I made
comparisons between Facebook and
communist Cuba where my distant cousins
are so moldering and now and that
anachronism yeah like I like to say
right it's like the famous quote from
from Churchill right that like democracy
is the worse is the worst way to
actually run a country other than all
the other ways that I've been tried
right so capitalism is like the worst
way to actually divide the spoils of the
means of production except all the other
ways that have been come up with right
and so yeah I mean what's the
alternative right but yeah no I think
capitalism makes beasts of us all in a
way and like what you're seeing in
Silicon Valley is like hyper capitalism
at the ultimate extreme in many ways and
I think a lot of the weirdness is that
you see in Silicon Valley like this
focus on meritocracy a meritocracy that
anyone who stays long enough in this
world realize it doesn't exist I mean
how else do you justify the fact that
two startups go and when one has a
billion dollar outcome and the other has
a zero outcome can that guy really claim
that he's a billion times better a
designer or product manager see and the
other guy of course not but you we all
have to pretend that he is right
otherwise how could you possibly justify
that that in that income inequality
right and so yeah these Epocrates are
what are the sort of lubricants that
keep the machine going in a way
fortunately
that sound too anarchist and yeah
all right who's next is that the line oh
sorry guys yeah in the book you talk
like one of the most scary things you
talked about was these companies that
tracks everything that's delivered to
our homes I was wondering if you talked
more about that and you also talked
about how ad blockers are effectively
stealing yeah so like what is like are
these companies doing us a service do we
owe them that information right sort of
thing here in case you hadn't read the
book there's like a Big Brother chapter
in which I say and just where I put my
Facebook ad on that like Facebook it
really isn't a big brother it's these
companies called like axiom and epsilon
Experian that have been tracking you
like literally since like the 60s right
since since before men have walked on
the earth and nobody knows about this
but like all that [ __ ] you get in the
mail believe it or not that's still a
multi-billion dollar business and and
those companies know literally who lives
in your house their income level their
education level and then when they join
to an actual third-party advertiser like
Target or Bed Bath and Beyond they join
that data with all those discount cards
you use that's basically used as a
vehicle for data joining right and so
exactly what you bought in the store
like in the physical store right like
diapers personal products whatever
that's all known right and the big
challenge part of what the story is
about is joining that massive mountain
of offline data to the online world and
there's still a gap there historically
it's been very hard to do just because
it's you know basically the prime what a
technologist would call a primary key to
the database is your name and address
right but on the online world the
primary key is either cookie in the
browser or the device ID on your mobile
device so basically a lot of what
Facebook is doing is basically joining
your browser or your device literally
this to an address that is joined to the
fact that you bought a 12-pack of
condoms last night whether you know it
or not right and then showing you the
appropriate ID based on that right and
so you know those come you know at the
other day Facebook and I sound like a
total facebook plan you know what cares
about you as a user because they really
care about maintaining your eyeballs on
the platform and they consider ads to be
kind of a necessary evil to sort of pay
the light bill and so at the end of the
day they actually want to please you but
the you know the guy who wants to sell
you a sweater or whatever at any cost he
kind of doesn't right and so anything
the weird thing is that it's weird it's
like people and it sounds horribly
douchey but when people like we use
Facebook it's like almost like a toddler
that hasn't learned object permanence
they say Oh Facebook showed me an ad
whatever Facebook isn't really showing
you anything it is a messaging system
that takes either you know your browser
cookie or the fact that you're at 37 in
Mountain View on Thursday at 7 o'clock
and then shows you a message right it's
like when you get a piece of email spam
like for like I don't know penis pills
or something does anyone say cut damn it
Google is showing the ads for penis
pills of course not because you
understand that in some sense they're
just a messaging system right or let me
know when you get a marketing called you
blame 18 key for it no right you
understand that it's somebody trying to
get you right the Facebook ad system
effectively is the same I think people
don't understand because everyone sends
the email and phone calls but no one's
actually like run an ad and so they
don't understand that effectively ads
are basically a paid messaging system
right and so anyway I guess my question
might my answer your question is you
should be worried about what the
advertiser knows and does about you and
less about Facebook because at the end
of the day they care about keeping you
using the app and not they don't care
about the money so much and the other
you mention the ad blocking is actual
interesting so Pizza News Facebook
basically said that it's going to block
the ad blockers and so so bad blockers
there's a piece of software that you
download and that it basically it knows
the actual endpoint ie the addresses of
where ads actually come from and then it
just basically doesn't load those pixels
in your browser and so it's a way of
browsing the internet without actually
loading an ad right and now and
historically that was like a minimal
usage like a few percentage points right
but now it's like the Wall Street
Journal I think came out with a piece
but like a quarter of Internet users
have an ad blocker now so now it's gone
from like you know I said the example
you know a retail establishment has like
what's called shrinkage or you shop
lifting right like one or two percent
just gets lost right and so ad blocking
used to be like a shrinkage problem and
now it's like no now it's like a major
problem it's like wholesale impressions
are being stolen and so Facebook
basically said look we're going to block
the ad blockers which they can do
because they they serve their own ads
and so a piece of software looking at
Facebook trying to find the ad could
actually get easily confused because
it's all coming from Facebook it's not
coming from an ad server or whatever and
so and of course there's going to be ad
blocker blockers and ad blocker blocker
blockers and blocker blocker blocker and
so on right in the arms race goes on but
I'm I mean I do think at the end of the
day that yeah you it's a minor form of
piracy if you run an ad blocker it
really is and I know it sounds like a
total douchey thing to say but if you
actually ran a site and realized how
much work a lot of people standing here
actually do to actually make Facebook
load X Facebook is a quarter of the
everywhere except China think about that
a quarter of the internet right there's
billions of photos uploaded every you
know every day and I know that feels
like the marginal cost is free but it's
not free to run right there's entire
towns in Oregon whose entire livelihood
is basically keeping Facebook machines
cool that's their entire reason for
existence the cooling system to a
[ __ ] Facebook machine right and so
that is not cheap right and so you use
it and it feels like it's free but it's
really not right and so yeah I do think
it's a form of theft anyway that said of
course that's that hold on but just to
clarify it is the case that some
publishers basically don't give a [ __ ]
about user experience and they abuse it
in that case I can see how one would be
tempted to use it but I think Facebook
very rarely inserts a really
disagreeable ads experience as you often
get on mobile and so but yeah I think
the real problem there is that
publishers just don't care that's the
real problem actually or many publishers
don't care okay long long answer to a
short question
go ahead sure so I just happen to move
to the to the valley six weeks ago to
support my husband's job at you know my
retweeted yeah so it's amazing I'm still
reading it and it's very dark and in a
way kind of reminds me of louis c.k but
in a very weird way anyway my question
was are you kind of also thinking about
at some point churning it out as a book
as a movie I mean is that kind of in
there I mean ideally it's the only way
to make money in books it's actually TV
but um weird yeah the agent is hustling
trying to alter that now but it's it's
weird like I'm only starting to learn
this but there's so many steps along the
way to actually getting a movie made
basically every movie you watch is like
a minor miracle right like a book deals
it's a book deal like HarperCollins
publishes it and short of whatever then
blowing up it's going to happen but to
get to a movie there's so many steps
along the way there's really no
guarantee by the way it's funny I don't
know if I wrote this in the tweet thing
I think I did but it's funny that you
mentioned that you I guess you're
reading the book is your husband's
attack right and so it so many people
have told me that they actually bought
the book for their family members in
fact is Riesman here one of the guys in
the book bought it for his therapist
because he just said look this is just
going to save time like [ __ ] me paying
you 30 bucks an hour to go through this
just by just read the [ __ ] book and
then we'll talk and so that so yeah I
think it's been a good like ecosystem
manual for like the people around the
people who work in text
yes Anton you know I really like what
you wrote on what you wrote about axiom
um I work at axiom I directly there Oh
alkyl and what do you have no idea where
that Kim does we go to the website
you'll never figure out where Kim does
it's a secret company today um a
thousand five hundred pieces of data on
every consumer pretty much around the
world
Wow way beyond what anybody realizes yep
but anyway my question is about Twitter
where do you think what's gonna happen
to Twitter yeah Twitter yeah so the
context there of course is I sold my
company Twitter but then I bailed in a
deal I went to Facebook and then after
the Facebook thing because people here
lives in a memoryless state I went back
in advice wait for two years to help
them with an acquisition for evidence so
I have some view into Twitter but I was
never there as a full-time employee so I
should say that I don't know them deeply
well I just know some of the members of
the ads team yeah I think the problem
with Twitter I think is part of the
reason why Facebook has done so well is
that you know Facebook has like a genius
founder CEO and I meant and I mean that
in the way I meant in the book were he's
a force of nature that has just created
this thing right that just will live on
for a long time and I think Twitter is
missing that level of leadership right
now right and the reality is that you
whether at the smallest level a
three-person startup or even at the
massive level of public tech company you
need to have someone who can like make
the bet the company moves in some
direction right because the technical
world I mean it's kind of a cliche
metaphor it's like a it's like a ship in
a stormy ocean right and at some point
you just have to decide to go in this
direction and the entire company lives
or dies by that decision that's what it
is and it seems to me like Twitter has
been sitting there spinning its wheels
for a long time and then you know the
growth problem right like a product with
the network effect doesn't have a steady
state constant usage curve right it's
either crowing or it's dying there's no
in-between right and it seems to be kind
of in between those two states right now
right and so yeah it's a little bit
worrying which is a shame because I you
know again I work with their ads teams
in there and they were very bright and
they were very forward-looking in many
ways more than Facebook but you know
execution OSB division always and
Facebook has the execution
hey like somewhat related to Twitter I
mean one of the parts of the book
obviously is you know what she described
about selling it and then and I wonder
it seemed like you know at the time you
were sort of thinking hey this is better
for me to go to Facebook like my two
co-founders they're gonna go to Twitter
like I think - it was in the Booker on a
podcast it seemed like they actually may
be made out better in the end and you
wonder one what you think about that
like if you you know would do it
differently again or just I mean I guess
that's maybe some of the random fit
cover the ditch
yeah so I actually mentioned in the
epilogue he I guess give them out to the
epilogue yeah yeah so I think here by
the way Michael refiners know okay so
yeah our garrison NMR em it's funny the
company that we started was literally
two blocks that way I just realized
since it's my my first time here in
several years so yeah no I think they
yeah they did do well I mean they're
still there actually and they're like
what five or six years and counting
investing lives and so ya know they did
do better knighted and in retrospective
I was of always worried about the
monetary outcome but yeah I should have
gone to Twitter actually it would have
been I think a better quality grass is
always greener right but I think we have
a better quality of life I would have
actually have stayed there for years
rather than getting chewed up by the
Facebook machined and yeah it would have
been a very different outcome but but
this book wouldn't exist another one the
fact that a lot of these sales
what impact is that have on the sternum
I'm maturing and what then Facebook
really did and I'll being company their
second business right and it creates a
real corporate environment right so
what's it doing to that startup side oh
I think it's a huge opportunity for
start of people because then you can eat
their lunch right I mean look at
companies like whatsapp Instagram and
snapchat right
they created user mobile user
experiences that Facebook didn't see
coming or couldn't build or copy
themselves oh well they bought it
eventually but because snapchat they
couldn't and you know there it is right
and they've got massive balance sheet
and they can buy out these companies
that they want to be bought out or not
or whatever but I think it's it's
nothing but opportunity right when the
older generation dies it's usually a
bigger opportunity for the younger
generation oh god no I mean well no I
don't think so it's funny because I
thought this would be like professional
suicide but it turns that the reaction
has actually been way less negative than
I thought
and so like I guess I don't have to flee
to Spain I guess so I guess I could have
I wanted to but we'll see how long I can
do this writer thing well so if you read
to the end you know when the mother died
and I hate to be as impressing things
when I had a whole chapter on the mother
dying at the end I was like all weepy
and [ __ ] and then my editor said you've
gone from like liars poker for like
Angela's Ashes you just want to press
the hard everybody it's totally out of
tone you've got to kill the chapter and
so the massive mother dying thing was
gone it just became like one line in the
UH plot venía in that in that experience
I can tell you the story now I guess
because I guess we've still got time you
know when your mother dies right and
it's you know the usual thing
misdiagnosed and then like unsuspected
stage for liver cancer right you
basically watch or waste away and die
over three months right and and I'm sure
people have had that experience if you
spend time in the cancer ward right and
you're just encounter with like the
yawning law of the grave right and there
was this experience this was in Miami
but they had like a hallway in a circle
where they try to get you know these
poor dying cancer people to come at walk
and like you know move and get some
exercise and you know I was in like this
haze of lack of sleep because you're
taking turns watching your mother or
whatever and so coming out of the I
could have elucidated it for all I know
coming out I feel like a young dude who
kind of looks like me and most everyone
there is old right you don't see a lot
of young people the guy looks like me
like standard-issue little Miami
Cubans eat like 30-something direct like
me basically but using that ridiculous
gown with like the little Ivy thing and
kind of chugging along like looking like
a little spectre of death right and for
some reason I flash to that scene in
Fight Club I'm sure everyone here seen
Fight Club right there's a scene in
which they drive into the wrong lane on
the highway right and the bad character
asks everybody in the car and there's
like a semi coming right if you're to
die right now what would you most regret
doing right and the each sing out like
one I think is called a house the other
is kind of self portrait and then like
the week sort of wimpy character kind of
just freaks out right it's kind of this
lesson of like if you're confronted with
death what would you regret doing and so
in that moment of feeling I was in the
headlights walking along with this guy
who's gimping along on the hallway the
only two things I could think of was
writing and publishing this book and the
other was actually finally realizing the
childhood dream of failing either around
the world or across an ocean on on a
sailboat right which is a dream that I
always had right when I was there I had
two different ocean-going sailboats that
I sort of worked on and prepared and
then just basically let right at the
dock because of this right the man and
so I said that's it it's not going to
happen again no matter what it takes I'm
going to do that and so yeah now that
I've done item number 1 I think it's
time for item number 2 of course I had
this other kid so who knows but I think
it's still going to be the top priority
items oh no no no no he's not coming now
the mother isn't it the mother isn't a
sailor so I don't know I don't think so
yeah Oh oh good that's that's a total
show question I so there's this race
called the Golden Globe raised if any
are familiar with sailing history that's
the first time that a human sailed
around the world alone without stopping
and it was held in 1968 and they're
doing a redo in 2018 and I entered it
and got accepted but I'm having second
thoughts about it because it's in two
years and I have to get the boat to the
UK and this book books taken huge amount
of times I will see but even if I don't
do the race the plan is still there to
sail the Salem to Sydney head where
you're from and either continue or sail
back
well Oh what do you think about the
future of Silicon Valley with our insane
costs and dude I don't know my question
above my paygrade I've been here for a
while I mean just I mean okay if you
want to go high level and all Bernie
Sanders I think there something I think
I mean I quote in the book right that
Marc Andreessen has a famous quote in
the future you had to tell the computer
what to do in the computer tells you
what to do right and if you look at
things like I go to Y C's demo day right
which is that where they pitch right and
for a while there maybe not so much
anymore like every YC company was
basically coding somebody out of a job
like literally every single [ __ ] one
was either using you know machines and
automation to wipe out blue-collar labor
or using code to wipe out white-collar
labor right like literally every single
startup right so there's a whole raft of
people that are just not going to have
jobs in 20 30 years right and if you
read that that that medium post that
went viral about the impact of
autonomous driving just take a concrete
case like we're going to have
self-driving cars in ten years like that
is happening right and it turns out that
truck driving is actually like one of
the few jobs that a high school-educated
male in some flyover State can actually
use to feed a family and that job is
going to go away and so is the diner
waitress and the guy pumping the gas and
the entire system around our entire
truck driven economy that's all going to
go away right and what happens when that
happens right we think we're seeing
something weird not with Trump and like
the distress that's happening in these
flyover States just wait until 20 years
from now when all their jobs are gone
basically not just a manufacturing jobs
right and and I think not a lot of
people actually thinking about that
although some people in Silicon Valley
are YC is doing an experiment and
universal basic income in Oakland I
think is very interesting and so you
know I think questions like that are
really the deep questions that I think
very few people are actually thinking
about yeah
well we've got time ask me anything
oh yeah so it's funny I'm surprised
nobody trolled me here the negative
feedback tends to be of a few flavors
usually it's the misogyny thing because
they think it's a sexist book which for
the record I don't think is a sexist
book actually but that's a whole long
rabbit hole probably need to go down
unless someone wants me to talk about it
which I'm happy to but as long as
nobody's recording it but um the other
thing is that it's weird I think they
just don't realize like they disliked
either the town or the negativity or the
general kind of [ __ ] II sociopathic
nature of the Meritor which to some
degree was me at the time but what they
don't realize like they don't dislike me
or the book they just dislike Silicon
Valley
I just portrayed it accurately right and
it's weird
everyone was an insider well including
you right has come and said oh wow this
is [ __ ] awesome in fact it's not so
awesome I have PTSD flashbacks it's like
the opening scene in Saving Private Ryan
for like a World War two veteran right
they're like here the bullet sound and
suddenly they're there again right and
Seth had so many people write me saying
my god I read your book and it stressed
me out so much because it reminded me of
like random [ __ ] X that was exactly
like mine or even worse right and so the
insiders love it but I think a lot of
the outsiders hate it because they've
got this like beautiful varnished image
of how Silicon Valley works right I mean
they buy the narrative fallacy right
they see through Houston or Zack on the
cover of fortune and they imagine these
proud visionaries and steely-eyed
execution and perfect product markets it
and everything is unfolds and it's
wonderful right and so they read this
move like oh they feel like they got
deceives them out like that's that's not
how it is it's like nobody this is how
it is right you just don't realize it
and so yeah a lot of people who are
relatively I'm a marketing professor
dinged it for being negative or
something and it's like you just yeah so
that's that's a lot of the negatives
almost all the negative feedback funnily
enough has been from total Silicon
Valley Outsiders I've yet to be get
serious troller II from a Silicon Valley
insider exa no should I okay even from
PCs I yes B C's I know if you should
name them yeah no well he'd been in a
public post I could say to Bill Tahu I
mentioned the book was very positive on
it
Chris Sacca see here cotton trading
higher he was not de positive but we
were not on great speaking terms anyhow
so
whatever I sent him a copy of the book
and I haven't heard back and only one
guy mentioned the book that I dumped on
a little bit he kind of renamed him but
he responded and kind of was a little
defensive but I think ultimately he was
still positive on the book and he
finished it so yeah oh [ __ ] no of course
not they would never cleared any of this
I got names so it's funny and this this
will be a horrible gateway drug that I
probably shouldn't say but it turns out
n TAS are kind of like insider trading
or like hate speech like we use those
terms very loosely but in fact they
actually covered they've actually don't
cover very much like they literally
cover like a document that you pilfered
out the CFO's desk and like give it
somebody like at the time like that's
what it actually covers things like your
personal politics or your personal
recollections are actually not covered
by that at all and if anything is known
to the public which doesn't mean anyone
on the street knows it it means that in
some way it was announced in public
including all this data matching [ __ ]
which by the way is totally public just
nobody knows about it is not covered
under the NDA and by the way if any
company partner knows about it someone
outside of the confidentiality barrier
has been told about it it's also not
confidential right and so yeah at the
end of the day there was nothing those
confidential and the good thing is for
all the problems this country might have
it still has freedom of speech and we
have really weak libel laws fortunately
which means that truth is always a
defense and so you'll note any scene in
which I'm saying something a little bit
dodgy about somebody it's always in a
meeting or it's always in an email that
could always be discovered under
subpoena or under a deposition right so
there always be somebody that could back
it up and said yeah that guy said that
done and so you can get away with a lot
more than you think actually
were the only ones I didn't name my name
are the women who were in you know some
slightly compromised position because I
didn't want to make it public I mean
everyone in my circle knows who they are
but I didn't want it to be like a public
thing so yeah the women have pseudonyms
but everyone else's name by name
so I never consulted anyone about it
because then it would just be just like
he said she said and like everyone
trying to make their edit or whatever
but I did tell British trader and I did
tell PMS the little broom-closet seen
that that she was getting mentioned but
they were both pretty cool with it and I
know both of them and I knew that they
wouldn't really care so that's fine yeah
hi my husband dragged me out here
kicking and screaming so um I'd like to
know why this place out here doesn't
have a cool world-class art scene like
Miami right which is funny because if
yet if you had said this went years ago
I would've been like what but now Miami
definitely does have a cleansing it's
funny I was there a few years ago to
Winwood or what's now called Winwood and
you should just be over town and I used
to be like the most hideous place in the
world and it's amazing it's like way
cooler than soma is now you know
well what they'll I've already made
gross over generalization so I'll just
say it you know I think I mean look at
look at look at Mountain View right look
at Palo Alto right we're living in the
elusive the Elizabeth unit era of our
time right I mean this is the equivalent
of Florence during the time of Leonardo
right and when you look around does it
seem like a culture that actually
invests in things like architecture art
or any sort of long stuff you know Lance
long-standing notion of itself no of
course not right I mean look at the past
right or even go to New York right every
public building there every school every
hospital is named after some rich
douchebag who decided to like xb8 the
sins of his soul or compete for social
prestige by funding hospital I went to
Icahn hospital icons an [ __ ] great
but nonetheless he funded the said you
know this hospital somehow I've never
walked into a Google Hospital right of
course there are exceptions Benioff in
Zuckerberg both funded hospitals that's
great that they did that right but in
general I think the notion here of
giving back is funding other startups
which I guess is sort of a way of giving
back but it's not quite like you know
Carnegie building a library in every
American town and the early part of the
century which he did if you go around
some of those beautiful libraries all
over CR Carnegie
libraries actually and that's a legacy
that he left that you know that educated
a whole generation right and I somehow
II just that feeling of giving back or a
feeling of civil debt or like we want to
invest in the city just does not exist
because nobody cares and I don't know
the deep reason but that's just the
feeling I get
and like you look around this does not
seem like Florence in the 15th century
right there never Lee not patronizing
Michelangelo for sure right well the
gate yeah yeah right manner of course
there are exceptions there are actually
sure sure sure absolute your obviously
exceptions yeah yeah yeah yeah get right
back there some a different era that's
right yeah but these are obviously our
exception but I brought Lee I don't know
that that's true huh anything else we've
got five minutes left I think yeah I
don't know you ask the guys in the back
because they know better than me I know
I will quote one unnamed source and I
find it very surprising that things have
gone supposedly a lot more political and
I think why the book is interesting cuz
it covers the era when Facebook went
from crazy startup where you could like
blow up the plumbing and nobody [ __ ]
cared to being a very political sort of
place with a lot of structure to it and
this unnamed source said you know I
think Facebook is going to go isn't
become Microsoft before Google does
actually and so I find that very
surprising but uh yeah
Microsoft being compared to Microsoft's
not a good thing in general in Silicon
Valley so yeah all right any other
questions are we done
no no I'll designing the signing [ __ ]
sorry oh god right no no it's a gift
okay yeah there is a gap okay call for
you and your baby
oh my god so nice of you thank you
that's so great oh thanks I'll open it
thank everyone for coming tonight you
support the store
I was thank you for having me it's like
I think the biggest crowd I've ever had
actually I so appreciated on Telus book
is available for purchase it is in the
back of the store so if you like the
purchase and then have them sign I know
some people walked in with their copies
so he'll be happy to sign those as well